he was a success at everything he
touched but it came at a cost what was
your first big break because you're
doing a lot of commercials and things
but what was the first thing as a you
know as an actor you felt okay this is
this is this is a cool thing this is a
big thing
uh
but it was in it was in the tv
commercial world uh my first i would say
my fourth tv commercial booking was the
mac tonight campaign for mcdonald's
which turned into it was a regional a
campaign that was four four spots
running in california and then it became
ooh national mcdonald's is like
is interested because it was doing sales
figures it was the after 4 pm crowd we
were catering to there's a big crescent
moon head that's standing at a panel
when the clock strikes hey half past six
babe oh so it was a nightclub character
uh and so uh it was so then it went
national right and then it was so
successful nationally that it went
worldwide in other countries so i ended
up working doing 27 commercials as mac
tonight so you made a lot of money in a
three-year period yeah so a lot of them
already bought my first house with yeah
wow it was mcdonald's i owe them that so
even though i can't eat there now my
heart right but
yeah with your cholesterol but they have
some menu items you can do i don't wanna
yeah i'd give a salad why can't you
always get a salad mcdonald's yeah some
nuggets right wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait i don't know that's that's
kind of the deep fried mm-hmm yeah
you're not your friend but what was the
what was the big
the movie or the tv show or whatever it
was that was right well well
uh the mac tonight campaign is where
i've started meeting and learning uh
about the creature affects people in
hollywood land uh and so a lot of a lot
of creature effects people from
different big shops came and worked on
these different commercial shoots with
us you were interested in that no
i was interested in being a goofy
sidekick on a sitcom that's why i came
to hollywoodland i wanted to put my tall
skinny ostrich neck to work
new chin right and my new tune uh and so
i did not realize that uh that this
you know uh creature effects rubber bits
on on actors was it was really a career
option right i didn't seek it out but
once i had you know
after my first agent had you know
submitted me for all these roles that
were physical tomfoolery and you know
contorting or mime experience needed
because they need a movement blah blah
blah those roles often came with a look
that was glued on to you right right so
that's how i started meeting creature
affects people and then that reputation
and they would go spread my name around
their own community and then come i
would get phone calls at home
sidestepping agents and casting
directors hey doug we're at the shop
we're working on this alien character
but you want to come in for a quick
fitting to see if it's going to be good
for you so i would and then once it was
a good fit then then every all the
business people would get involved and
it would become a booking
so uh so kind of so my career kind of so
people liked you people like you doug
jones well no i don't want to boast i
just saw you in arkansas at a convention
and the first thing we just have a big
hug and a kiss and just
just friendly and and you're just that
guy you're that guy and it sounds to me
like you've always been that guy